jean pierre raffarin est l'invité de
preuves par 3 en ce jour crucial pour
l'ump et même c'est hors cat iq
pourrait-on dire bonsoir monsieur le
premier ministre
bonsoir monsieur aussi c'est à ce titre
que vous prenez effectivement la barre
de l'ump secoué par l'affairé bygmalion
avec deux autres anciens premiers
ministres françois fillon et alain juppé
bien sûr nous allons consacrer une large
partie de cette émission à l'ump plonger
dans les turbulences et qui réunira un
nouveau congrès ce sera à l'automne dans
quelles conditions bien vous allez
pouvoir nous le dira nous évoquerons
également la position plus que jamais
est confortable du chef de l'état
françois hollande et puis parlera aussi
de vos ambitions pour le sénat avec jean
lui prévôt de la fp et perrine tarneaud
de public sénat d'abord bien sûr le
départ au sein d'une démission
collective nous avons bien compris de
jean-françois copé de la présidence de
l'ump à l'issue d'un bureau politique
très tendu et ce qui l'attend est comme
on le dit jusqu'au bout de sauver sa
tête où il a été très digne il a été
dans un moment particulièrement
difficile dans une atmosphère parfois
insupportable humainement affectivement
insupportable raison d'un concurrent en
détention des démographes des
inquiétudes de de ce qu'il y avait de
tragique dans cette situation et
notamment par l'importance de cette
affaire qui a vraiment inquiété en même
temps qui a jeté une incompréhension et
puis il a plaidé son innocence avec
conviction il a été reconnu qu' il avait
droit à sa présomption d'innocence est
donc très dignement il a démissionné de
sa fonction il retrouve sa liberté il a
plaidé son innocence est ce que vous
avez tenté de l'aider vous
personnellement
vous l'aimez bien c'est votre expression
jean françois copé parce que vous avez
tenté de défendre le président de l'ump
démissionnaire dans ses dénégations
je n'ai pas pris comme cela dans cette
intervention plus que j'ai eu à faire
j'ai parlé en fonction de ma conviction
j'ai dit combien j'étais effondrée par
les nouvelles que que j'apprenais j'ai
dit combien notre parti étaient menacés
par un risque de disparition et qu'il
fallait mettre l'unité du parti au
dessus de tout et que pour les tic
il y avait une ligne qui s'imposaient à
tous qu'il fallait se rassembler et
qu'il fallait que jean françois copé en
son âme et conscience nous disent
qu'est-ce qu'il souhaitait faire et donc
je n'ai pas voulu que nous le fassions
il a fait un grand travail dans l'ue
peuvent sauver les élections municipales
il a fallu former des candidats les
sélectionner il a fallu faire beaucoup
de choses pendant ces deux ans donc il a
fait un travail il a pris sa
responsabilité en son âme et conscience
du monde de manière vive avril
responsabilités il annoncé il a annoncé
dès le début qu'il écouterait tout le
monde et qu'il dirait sa conclusion à la
fin lorsqu'il a tenté de proposer des
concessions non ils ont du sens non non
il était pas dans cette danse est je
dirais état d'esprit il était vraiment
dans un état d'esprit de gravité comme
nous tous il répondait à ce que nous
disions il y avait des attaques plus
féroces les unes que les autres
il y avait une équipe qui vous a
particulièrement son sujet je ne veux
pas je ne veux pas de parler de ce que
j'ai entendu mais il y avait quelques
fois des mots durs mais au total il y
avait quand même du respect il a du
respect pour la personne de jean
françois copé de son axe alors le coup
est rude pour lui bien évidemment et ce
qu'il va s'en remettre selon vous ça je
le crois je pense que il a une énergie
exceptionnelle ce reviendra je pense que
jean françois copé n'est pas sorti de la
scène politique il a un talent il a une
volonté et puis il a maintenant cette
conscience en lui même 2
son innocence et donc ça lui donne une
force
vous le croyez que cette force il devra
il devra l'exprimer donc je pense qu'il
exprimera mais ne croyez quand il se dit
innocent avec de la connaissance de ce
qui s'est passé avec ses comptes truqués
les phosphatiers je suis effondré par
les nouvelles mais je suis respectueux
de cette présomption d'innocence et je
dois comme tout le monde faire confiance
à la fois à jean françois copé est un
homme responsable qu'il est et à la
justice de nous dire la vérité c'est à
la justice de dire la vérité
aujourd'hui jean pierre raffarin diriger
l'ump ça veut dire collaborer avec la
justice ouvrir les portes des tiroirs
les armoires vais devoir répondre aux
sollicitations
ça veut dire chercher la vérité mais je
crois qu'il faut que la vérité sorte
il faut qu'on sache exactement ce qui
s'est passé et comment les choses se
sont passées qui a décidé quoi
et donc on a besoin de cette vérité et
on a besoin de coopérer avec la justice
de la manière la plus transparente même
vous pourriez répondre aux questions
d'un joli je pense que la police et la
justice doivent avoir des conditions de
travail qui soit complètement ouverte
pour tout homme et à sa disposition nous
mettons notre organisation à la
disposition de la police et de la
justice mais ça a déjà été fait par jean
françois copé est donc cesser la ligne
parce que ceux qui en avaient tous deux
commun y compris jean françois copé
c'est que tout le monde veut la vérité
parce que jean françois copé aussi lui
qui dit clairement qu'il n'était pas
informé veut savoir ce qui s'est passé
donc il y a un besoin de vérité partagez
vous vous dites notamment effondré par
la nature des révélations n'est ce pas
jean pierre a fermé est ce qu'on peut
croire par l'ampleur et ampleur par
l'ampleur des sommes concernées c'est
quelque chose te mens est ce qu'on peut
croire qu'un tel dépassement des comptes
de campagne de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 donc plus de 10
millions d'euros ait pu passer inaperçue
écoutez moi je ne suis ni juge ni
magistrats ni expert comptable il se
trouve qu'on est dans une procédure
judiciaire que la justice nous dise la
vérité
moi je veux la vérité et je compte sur
la justice pour établir la vérité et
c'est elle
nous fera conclure les prendre les
décisions que nous devons gérante et
ceux qui savaient était forcément plus
nombreux que ceux très peu trop
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui qui porte un
chapeau qui est trop grand pour écouter
sur ce sujet moi je ne veux pas dire
autre chose que ce qu'on dit les
personnes intéressées qui ont parlé avec
une sincérité souvent touchantes et bien
donc que la justice maintenant avec ces
différents témoignages nous dise la
vérité et ne nous comportons pas ni en
procureur ni en juge cette affaire
confiance à notre justice pour élucider
cette affaire
est ce que ces révélations de compliquer
le retour éventuel de nicolas sarkozy
écoutez je pense que nicolas sarkozy
mène une réflexion qui n'est pas achevée
de toute façon son parcours était en
grande partie extérieure à l'ump
donc nous verrons bien mais qu'on croit
que j'étais financé en partie par
m'écouter on va voir ce que va dire la
justice mais n'anticipons pas sur ce que
dira la justice pour le moment il faut
sauver l'unité de l'ump pour que nous
restions rassembler parce que nous avons
une espérance a porté sur la gouvernance
des dans ce pays et donc il nous faut
être capable de à la fois d'avoir une
forte éthique pour l'avenir de notre
parti est en même temps une bonne
gouvernance pour gérer les échéances à
venir alors l'éthique c'est notamment
respecter les plafonds de dépenses pour
les campagnes jean pierre raffarin
marine le pen estime que l'ancien chef
de l'état est disqualifié je pense que
naturellement dans cette affaire il ya
beaucoup de gens qui calcule il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas
extrêmement sincère de tous leurs côtes
mais là en l'occurrence madame le pen
donc moi je ne veux pas participer à ce
jeu de massacre
je vois bien que nous avons une
situation difficile à affronter
il faut l'affronter avec courage ce que
nous avons fait ce matin avec dignité et
éthique et avoir confiance dans la
justice et surtout chercher la vérité je
sais ce que par exemple nicolas sarkozy
est exposé à un risque dit
lisibilité pour demain je ne peux pas
vous dire c'était la justice à dire je
ne peux pas je ne veux pas que le bureau
politique ce matin ne s'est pas fait
juge ni magistrat ce n'est pas à nous
maintenant d'être juge magistrat
c'est à la justice de dire ce qu'il en
est nous nous devons veiller à ce que
les règles de l'éthique soit respectée
de a à z
c'est vrai que le nom de nicolas sarkozy
n'a pas été prononcé ce mardi matin lors
de votre bureau politique
je n'aurais pas souvenir il a pu l'être
mais je n'ai pas souvenir alors vous
voilà donc chargé d'une mission
d'intérim maison que je le disais tout à
l'heure avec alain juppé françois fillon
mais vous avez aussi devoir jouer les
arbitres en fait entre deux
présidentiables donc deux rivaux vous
allez être le juge de paix également
entre ces deux là écoutez les conditions
ne sont pas encore définis pour cette
gouvernance intérimaire
je pense que nous aurons d'ici le 15
juin un ou deux bureaux politiques
je pense que nous devons veiller à ce
que nos décisions soient compatibles
avec nos statuts et avec notre haute
autorité avec madame levade qui doit
nous dire précisément quel est le
calendrier est des décisions que nous
devons prendre et donc nous avons pris
une décision politique aujourd'hui il
faut qu'au prochain bureau politique on
met en forme juridiquement cette
décision dans le calendrier quelles sont
les missions exactes de l'intérim
parce que la terrible n'est pas une
présidence et définitive donc il ya des
responsabilités qui doivent être
définies ça nous savons et puis les
précautions qui devront être prises pour
le congrès pour le prochain scrutin
heure là jean françois copé a mis en
place cette haute autorité cette haute
autorité va nous donner les règles et
nous les respecterait ce que françois
fillon tient déjà depuis aujourd'hui sa
revanche je ne crois pas qu'il faut voir
une chose il faut pas voir les choses
comme ça et je pense que ce on aurait
tort de les voir comme ça parce que ça
voudrait dire que les tensions déjà un
certain temps perdure je pense qu'il
faut voir aujourd'hui que nous sommes
dans une crise mais que nous devons
organiser la survie de notre famille
politique autour de ses valeurs
autour de ses ambitions et de ses
projets et donc pour cela il faut faire
en sorte qu'on se rassemble
moi je suis l'un de ceux à l'ump qui
parle à françois fillon qui parle
jean françois copé qui parle à nicolas
sarkozy donc moi je tisse des liens avec
alain juppé et avec les autres et je
fais en sorte que la famille reste
rassuré car je sais que ce qui conduit à
l'échec c'est la division
est ce que françois fillon pour être
candidat à la présidence de l'ump à
l'automne s'il se présente comme il l'a
annoncé à la primaire il me dit nous en
délibérerons n'y a pas de règle à ce
jour et najib andy lui pas pour moi
c'est non c'est ce que dit alain juppé
nous en discuterons nous n'avons pas
encore discuté puisque je vous dis que
je veux l'unité donc je chercherai une
règle commune
mais il est clair que aujourd'hui je
pense que françois fillon a des qualités
pour assumer un certain nombre de
responsabilités est la jupe est aussi
comme jean françois copé en avait aussi
donc nous définirons ensemble les règles
et chacun est-ce qu'il faut avancer la
primaire c'est ce que certains réclament
à l'ump par exemple font crise en crise
terminée dès 2015
j'aime beaucoup franck riester qui est
un homme politique de grand talent et de
hautes responsabilités sur ce point je
ne suis pas d'accord avec lui parce que
le problème est que la personne qui
sortira de la primaire devra est en face
dans l'opinion pour la présidentielle et
donc rien ne nous dit que la
personnalité qui sera en phase avec
l'opinion en printemps 2015 sera la même
personne
il faudra avoir au printemps 2010 est
donc moi je pense qu'il faut faire comme
ça a été prévu dans nos statuts la
primaire en 2016 est ce que vous croyez
qu'une telle affaire jette des
bataillons de militants de l'ump dans
les bras de marine le pen c'est un des
sujets sur lesquels nous avons réfléchi
et qui nous a imposé ses décisions qui
sont au total douloureuse parce que je
pense qu'il y avait des risques de
départ au centre et de départ à droite
et donc il y avait ceux de ce danger là
et c'est pour ça que j'ai milité pour
que l'on recherche
aujourd'hui l'union dans notre famille
politique et qu'on puisse être assemblés
et notre décision collective ce matin a
été l'occasion d'une position que bien
est-ce que marine le pen ne s'installe
pas finalement après ces chocs en
cascade comme la seule opposante tout la
principale opposante à françois hollande
et elle est une opposante à françois
hollande ce qu'elle essaie d'établir
aujourd'hui c'est sa présence au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
je pense que encore on l'a vue fortement
avec les municipales on le voit avec les
européennes
s'il y avait un match de second tour
aujourd'hui ils seraient entre le front
national et l'ump et donc la situation
pour l'ump ne serait pas fortement
défavorable et vous savez il faut se
méfier des élections européennes vous
avez peut-être noté qu'il y avait une
élection législative à toulouse et que à
toulouse il y a une participation police
latif de 51% alors qu'elle est beaucoup
plus faible aux européennes est notre
candidat gagne le poste de député à
toulouse avec une nette majorité donc on
voit bien que l'élection législative
n'est pas l'élection européenne
donc madame le pen évidemment en faisant
ce score nous pose un problème politique
majeur
mais je crois qu'elle profite surtout de
l'effondrement du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui en pleine affaire big band
lyon certains au parti socialiste estime
que c'est un coup terrible pour la
république vous êtes d'accord avec cette
vision et cette formule je pense que
l'om profite pas au parti républicain
je pense que les socialistes mettre un
petit peu d'huile sur le feu sur tout
cela est
et au fond c'est sans doute leur intérêt
ce n'est pas forcément d'une hauteur de
vue exceptionnel surtout dans la
situation dans laquelle ils sont après
un effondrement électorale majeure est
dans une situation politique où le
président de la république dans le
sentiment d'être très absent même quand
il fait une intervention télévisée 7
cette intervention marque pas les
esprits alors justement nous allons jean
pierre raffarin évoqué maintenant le
sort de françois hollande depuis son
intervention au lendemain de ce scrutin
européen qui était une débâcle pour le
parti socialiste et pas du tout une
réussite pour l'ump plus inconfortable
que jamais donc la situation du chef de
l'état peut-il encore réformé peut-il
encore gouverné avant d'accueillir jean
louis prévost de l' agence france-presse
état des lieux à l'elysée avec faustine
saint geniès ce vote c'est une défiance
à l'égard de l'europe une prise de
parole qui s'apparente à un coup d'épée
dans l'eau
même à l'elysée tout le monde n'était
pas d'accord sur son opportunité
le chef de l'état fait face à une
situation intenable après la débâcle de
dimanche
tentative d'explication de ces quatre
minutes d'intervention solennel à 20
heures françois hollande a essayé sur la
forme à la fois de jouer de la
présidentialité il est dans les
bibliothèques de l'elysée est à la fois
par sa gestuelle de montré une
combativité alors évidemment c'est au
service du moment à l'issue d'une grave
défaite électorale le fait que le front
national arrive en première position
pas question de changer de politique la
ligne vient juste d'être défini un
nouveau premier ministre vient juste
d'être nommé bref il faut maintenir le
cap
quelle qu'elles étaient bien annoncer de
nouvelles mesures tous les jours une
nouvelle mesure
non le cap est fixé c'est celui du
redressement de la france dans la
justice le cap est fixé c'est celui
d'une meilleure répartition de la
richesse de cap est fixé se jure de la
baisse d'impôt pour les couches
populaires et les classes moyennes c'est
ça la réalité
pourtant le moral des troupes est au
plus bas au parti socialiste
chez les députés l'ambiance était
glaciale ce mardi et les critiques ont
fusé en présence de manuel valls
l'un d'eux a même évoqué un problème
françois hollande pour ce qu'on attend
du président a vu qu'aujourd'hui plus
que
sa déclaration d'hier c'est qu'ils
affichent clairement ce qu'est
l'intention de la france il est probable
que sa déclaration était d'abord destiné
à rassurer ses voisins européens parce
que comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure elle n'avait pas vraiment de
nécessité au plan national
françois hollande plus affaiblie que
jamais participé aujourd'hui à un dîner
informel à bruxelles
un numéro d'équilibriste en perspective
pour une france en perte d' influence
voilà jean louis prévost des fêtes avec
nous pensons jean-louis vos questions à
jean pierre raffarin bonsoir monsieur
raffin alors la déclaration de françois
hollande hier vous nous dites il est
venu pour ne rien dire
je pense que on pouvait attendre une
intervention du président de la
république en cette situation de gravité
politique avec le score du front
national
un message qui soit à la fois plus
vigoureux et en même temps un certain
nombre de réflexions sur la situation du
pays et notamment sur ses deux priorités
qui devraient être certes l'emploi
mais pour le moment je ne vois pas venir
le fameux pacte de responsabilité que
nous attendons toujours depuis le 14
janvier
ça va faire bientôt six mois d'annoncés
sans action et puissent deuxièmement
qu'ils nous proposent des initiatives
institutionnelles je pense pour
réconcilier les français et la politique
parce que le vote de dimanche
ça veut dire que vous journalistes et
moi politique on est en partie coupé du
pays et ça c'est un vrai problème
républicain et moi j'attends que le
président de la république dise comment
on va rapprocher le politique de la
norme de l'olympique nous proposez quoi
vous suggérer quoi rapprocher
je pense qu'il ne pourra pas se
contenter de son big bang territorial
alors quoi et encore son big bang
territorial faudrait-il qu'ils le
classement révèle alors avec mes
blessures je pense qu'il faut moderniser
le parlement par exemple il faut un
parlement plus efficace il faut rénover
le sénat il faut dynamiser l'assemblée
nationale
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont à
faire alors y at il un problème hollande
comme certains le disent au psg trouvait
le président de la république très
absent il est un peu
en suspension dans notre débat politique
je trouve que il a des bonnes
interventions épisodiquement
mais entre deux interventions on ne voit
pas l'action on ne voit pas ni la
perspective est ni la recherche du
résultat
alors vous êtes bouchard je crois qu'il
n'a pas réussi à inverser la courbe de
l'efficacité du passage à l'acte
je crois que c'est un bon analyste mais
que sur le plan de l'acte il est assurée
il a encore les moyens d'agir de moins
en moins c'est pour ça que ça les choses
vont devenir difficiles c'est que de
moins en moins la capacité d'action
d'abord déjà dans un quinquennat
c'est au début que se font les réformes
le plus lourd et dense est au début pour
mais les grands chantiers et en plus
quand on est à ce degré d'impopularité
et de désaveu l'action devient difficile
alors vous voulez dire qu'il pourrait ne
pas achever son quinquennat non je ne le
pense pas nous avons des institutions
très forte mais en tout cas ce que je
crains c'est que les choses continuent
comme elles sont en train de se passer
c'est à dire que le président intervient
la télévision ça n'intéresse pas grand
monde qu'au total tout ceci passe comme
sur une toile cirée ça cool mais ça ne
marque pas ça n'imprime pas la question
fondamentale est ce que le président de
la république veut oui ou non
incarner la france quand il va voter en
voiture avec ses sacs les français
demande auprès de la république d'aller
passer dix heures dans une voiture pour
aller voter
personne n'en voudra auprès d'un public
de prendre son avion d'aller voter et de
witte de rentrer à l'elysée pour
travailler et l'aurait sans doute plus
normal de prendre la voiture c'est au
fond pour un président le refus
d'assumer cette fonction exceptionnelle
qui est l'incarnation de la france avait
seulement est ce que le premier ministre
manuel valls un quart de plus la
fonction selon vous parce que lui il a
tenu un discours un presque
présidentielle dans le ton dès dimanche
soir où la nouveauté projet noté le
présidentielle c'est beaucoup dire
c'est beaucoup c'était d'ailleurs les
deux discours aurait été utile s'il
avait été prononcée peut-être pendant la
campagne électorale pour le score du
parti socialiste parce que ils ont fait
les discours comme ça
où les bureaux de vote sont fermés ce
qui n'est pas très efficace mais sur le
plan de la relation entre matignon et
l'elysée
il est clair que manuel valls a
aujourd'hui une dynamique est en fait
une volonté d'imprimer son sa
responsabilité sur le terrain dans
l'action ça va poser un problème à un
moment ou un autre si le président régis
passe l'envié est ce que françois
hollande a raison de marteler comme le
fait manuel valls qu'il n'ya qu'une
ligne et on s'y tient
bien sûr le président de la république
est celui qui fixe le cap et donc c'est
lui qui fixe la ligne mais le problème
c'est que quand il vit le 14 janvier
je veux un pacte de responsabilité pour
ne se retrouve pas à la mi juin sans
rien à boire de tout ce qu'il a annoncé
alors parce que l'emploi je vois ça dans
mon département de la vienne et mes
collègues sénateurs sont nombreux à
chaque mardi à notre région du groupe
ont fait la liste des entreprises en
difficulté on voit toutes les
difficultés qu'ont les pme aujourd'hui
et bien perdre six mois c'est une grave
faute politique
quand il s'agit d'emplois vous avez un
programme d'urgence pour lui je pense
qu'il ya pas mal de choses qui seraient
passés nécessaire très vite oui comme
lesquelles par exemple la jal en charge
ils sont décidés ces 30 milliards
pourquoi attendre pour les engagés par
exemple quelque chose qui ne coûte rien
doubler tous les seuils le seuil de 50
ans le versant le seuil de 100 ma 207
effectifs des entreprises c'est plus
facile pour embaucher plus facilement
mais aussi pour certaines cotisations
il y à il y à une série de seuil qui
aujourd'hui fred le développement doit
suspendre la réforme pénale de
christiane taubira
je pense qu'il ferait mieux de en effet
d'avoir des gestes de cette nature pour
rassembler sur les sépare je crois tout
à fait et responsable que d'annoncer une
réforme qui permette le droit de vote
des étrangers à quelques jours d'une
élection européenne
je pense qu'il y a des textes de lois
qui sont aujourd'hui agitée pour être
des symboles politiques quand on est à
deux ans de responsabilités que à trois
ans de la prochaine échéance qu'est ce
qu'on attend de notre président sait
qu'il agisse je vais vous dire très
franchement ma conviction c'est la
faiblesse du président ne servent
personne nous n'avons pas intérêt aux
échecs du président de la république
parce que les échecs du président sont
les échecs de la france est dotée vous
qu'il a encore des chances pour 2017
il ne fait pas grand chose pour les
améliorer ses chances par définition je
suis réaliste et je connais les
institutions de la vème république la
fonction est très attachant résidents ne
vais pas changer absolument un président
a toujours une puissance institutionnels
réel mais il faut dire que la situation
aujourd'hui du président de la
république est catastrophique
je pense dans son action mais je pense
aussi dans son attitude et dans la
capacité qu'il a a refusé d'incarner la
france de ses outils constitutionnels
c'est la dissolution mais vu l'état de
l'ump se serait pas forcément une
opportunité pour vous ce qu'elle serait
quand même souhaitable pour sortir de
cette quasi crise c'est votre mot une
quasi crise présidentielle
oui je pense que la situation est grave
pour le président de la république
elle est grave à l'international c'est
lui qui est confronté à la perte de
crédibilité de la france vis-à-vis de
tous les grands dirigeants du monde donc
il va sentir quand il va être au sommet
européen dans le regard des autres dans
l'attitude est observée dans les
relations internationales
le rapport de force ça compte on se
regarde dans les yeux on va à lorient le
joueur brugeois bien celui qui est fort
est celui qui est faible donc lui même
il va ressentir cette faiblesse de la
france dans ses relations en béton il
veut réorienter l'europe bien sûr c'est
pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont été dites sur le débat européen il
faut qu'on se remette tous en cause avec
ce résultat nous mêmes les européens
nous devons nous remettre en cause parce
que nos arguments ne passe pas on voit
bien que quand on parle de la paix quand
on parle de la force continentale de
l'europe
on voit bien que tout ceci n'est
intéresse pas suffisamment n'ai pas
compris donc il faut que les européens
se remettent eux aussi en cause pour
reconstruire un message européen alors
justement il avancé une idée que l'union
européenne devra se retirer de là où
elle n'est pas nécessaire est ce que
vous approuvez cette île ça fait 20 ans
qu'on dit ça et on ne le fait pas le
problème aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir de
l'influencé pour convaincre madame
merkel c'est de la force qu'il faut
c'est pas de dire non
la france aujourd'hui voudraient ceci
voudrait cela il faut pouvoir convaincre
madame merkel d'abord il faut ensuite
convaincre les 27 autres et donc il y a
cette nécessité aujourd'hui d'être fort
d'avoir une influence diplomatique le
pouvoir aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une
capacité individuelle c'est une capacité
collective celle influence sur un groupe
dans l'europe et donc il faut pas faire
croire aux français que c'est un
président français à lui seul change il
change s'il arrive à d'abord à
convaincre allemagne et s'il arrive à
séduire les autres c'est le monde des
étapes et maintenant la france vu de
l'étranger avec un front national 25%
des suffrages exprimés c'est une
nouvelle tâche là sur notre image je
pense que la france va souffrir de stage
je me souviens quand l'autriche avaient
voté pour l'extrême droite
combien elle avait souffert quant à son
image internationale donc c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
moi je dis clairement à nous aux
français qui nous écoutent que j'ai
entendue depuis dimanche beaucoup de
bavardages et vu naturellement beaucoup
de calculs mais j'ai vu peu de remise en
cause
moi je pense que les européens doivent
se remettre en cause je pense qu'une des
raisons de notre faiblesse il faut y
réfléchir c'est qu'on ne parle pas
suffisamment de la mondialisation dans
notre pays on est le seul pays
aujourd'hui qui parle de
démondialisation qui a une vision
idéologique de la mondialisation
or en fait la mondialisation c'est quoi
c'est la chine plus le brésil plus les
etats-unis +2 canada c'est à dire des
gens qui défendent des intérêts donc
quand on dit on va faire une
mondialisation ceux ci on va faire une
mondialisation solar est ce qu'on est
capable de faire changer la chine est ce
qu'on est capable de faire changer le
président non la mondialisation est là
et la dialectique qui se développe en
france et le choix entre eux la france
et l'europe
à mon avis c'est pas ça le sujet le
sujet c'est la france et le monde
et quand on regarde la france dans le
monde à ce moment là on s'aperçoit qu'on
a besoin de l'europe et donc je crois
que ce qui est très important c'est
qu'on réfléchisse c'est peut-être pas la
bonne solution mais je crois qu'il faut
qu'on change notre discours il faut
après un vote comme ça se remettre en
cause je pense que le gouvernement
devrait remettre en cause toutes ces
réformes qui sont des dires forme de
diversion qui ne sont pas
par exemple critiqué qui devrait et qui
devrait se concentrer le gouvernement
sur l'emploi sur la dynamique économique
je pense que nous dans l'opposition
notamment les européens on a un travail
à faire pour rendre notre message plus
moderne
c'est pas normal que les jeunes
aujourd'hui n'est pas le goût de le rock
faut réfléchir à cela et c'est pas les
jeunes qui ont tort c'est nous qui ne
savons pas leur présenter l'europe comme
il le faut et donc il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à sa aussi remise en cause
et puis il faut sans doute remettre en
cause aussi très clairement ce score du
front national je vous le disais quand
vous voyez le résultat des législatives
de toulouse
vous vous dites c'est parce que
finalement les gens disent aux
municipales je vois tu ump mais aux eaux
européennes
je vote notamment pour le front national
et surtout si je suis de gauche
n'oublions pas que jamais le front
national n'est plus fort quand la gauche
est au pouvoir ou la présence de marine
le pen au second tour en 2017 n'est pas
une fatalité
ce n'est pas une fatalité mais c'est une
responsabilité de la gauche de la gauche
par sa politique et quelquefois par sa
malice contribuer au développement du
front national exemple le droit de vote
des étrangers
à quelques jours du vote mais ça ne lui
profite plus on l'a vu merci jean louis
prévost il est le parti socialiste est
la première victime de cette stratégie
perrine tarneaud de public sénat arrive
pour évoquer bien notamment une réforme
peut-être même la réforme sur laquelle
compte françois hollande pour bell
laissé son empreinte on va en parler
maintenant c'est la nouvelle carte de la
france ce un mur de chine c'est un peu
sa dernière carte à jouer
celle d'une france redécouper après un
big bang territorial
françois hollande ne changera pas plus
de cap que des kits gouvernementale la
rupture réclamé viendra donc de la
réforme territoriale
les choses vont aller assez vite une
fois que le président va parler des
textes sont en préparation d'ores et
déjà qu'ils seront soumis au conseil des
ministres avant la fin du mois de juin
et on va essayer de commencer à débattre
de cette question de cette grande
réforme initiée au sénat parce qu'on
commence toujours par le sénat quand
j'ai des territoires en juillet la
réforme aura lieu en deux temps d'abord
diviser le nombre de régions par deux
d'ici 2017 puis une possible suppression
des départements d'ici 2021 et c'est là
le principal risque de blocage
le groupe sur ce sujet reste très
protéiforme pour ne pas dire diviser
j'entends tous les avis et des avis qui
sont souvent divergents voire contraire
j'entends ceux qui disent qu'il faut
maintenir des comptes ont été
partenaires à tout prix ceux qui disent
qu'on peut être bien faire une réforme
qui ira au delà tout cela c'est possible
disparition des conseils généraux d'ici
2021 divise les sénateurs socialistes
les élus des territoires ruraux sont
inquiet le gouvernement serait donc prêt
à moduler la réforme pour préserver le
rôle des élus dans les zones rurales
pour la discussion que nous avons eue
avec manuel valls il nous a semblé qu'il
voulait prendre en compte justement
cette diversité des territoires et faire
en sorte que ce qu'on applique dans les
métropoles en ne l'appliquent pas dans
des zones plus rurales
mais même dans les zones urbaines
impossible de supprimer les conseils
généraux sans réviser la constitution
l'exécutif pense avoir trouvé la parade
en maintenant des conseils généraux
vidés de leur substance
mais pour les spécialistes cette
manoeuvre serait retoqué par le conseil
constitutionnel
on ne pas vider de sa substance les
départements tous les départements en
particulier
autant leur assemblée délibérante sans
leur laisser un minium de compétences
donc dans ce cadre gary fait passer par
une révision constitutionnelle une
révision constitutionnelle qui
nécessiterait soit un référendum
difficile à faire approuver pour un
exécutif aussi impopulaire soit un vote
du congrès où le président n'est pas sûr
d'obtenir la majorité nécessaire pour le
chef de l'état nous dit questions à jean
pierre raffarin sur ce thème et aux
autres encore bonsoir
alors on l'a vu dans ce reportage les
sénateurs socialistes sont visiblement
un peu pris de court le projet de loi
sur la décentralisation notamment sur
les régions va être examiné en conseil
des ministres la semaine prochaine il
devrait être examiné par le sénat au
début du mois de juillet ce qui est un
risque le sénat de gauche s'oppose au
gouvernement sur ce projet qui tient ses
forces et puisque vous avez pris de
court mais en fait on assiste à une
complète improvisation parce que le
président la république ce début de
l'année pro département puis anti
département on supprime la cause de
compétence générale
on remet la côte de compétence générale
ont supprimé la cause
on est dans une situation
d'improvisation et au fond il n'y a pas
de vision sur le sujet le sénat avait
pourtant fait le travail
on avait fait une émission qui a été
cité à plusieurs reprises en dix ans il
ya deux grandes perspectives où vous
faites des grandes régions et vous
gardez le département pour la proximité
et la grande région c'est la puissance
la grande région a fait les grandes
infrastructures
elle fait les éléments de stratégie et
le département il fait la proximité
schéma un schéma deux fusions ou
rapprochements région département et à
ce moment là plus de départements mais
un seul une seule collectivités région
département
ça c'était la logique du conseiller
territorial de nicolas sarkozy le parti
socialiste a fait une croix sur ce
projet et là maintenant il nous dit
grande région mais suppression des
départements
ça se fait un suppression des
départements c'est encore un petit peu
flou visiblement on veut garder les
conseils généraux mais les vider de leur
substance sur les buts de leur substance
dangereux de les vider de leur substance
parce que quand leur substance c'est le
social c'est la proximité la cohésion
sociale ça compte beaucoup dans notre
pays moi ce que je crains derrière tout
ça c'est que ce soit l'acte 1 de la
recentralisation
parce qu'on va redonner à l'état un
certain nombre de compétences si on les
enlève au département parce que vider de
leur substance de toute façon vous
n'allez pas vider le rsa vous allez bien
continuer la prime pour les handicapés
vous avez bien continuer un certain
nombre de prestations sociales ça veut
dire que l'état le ferais ça s'appelle
de la recentralisation actuel de la
recentralisation et nous ne pouvons pas
accepter la remise en cause du
département le département
c'est le lieu républicain de la
proximité
ceci étant ce qu'avait dit jean françois
copé qui lui oui vous voulez les
supprimer jean françois copé faisait
partie à l'intérieur de l'ump d'une
minorité qui est favorable à la
suppression des départements
nous nous sommes au sénat dans le groupe
ump unanime maintien du département qui
va fixer la ligne de l'ump en matière de
décentralisation c'est laisser l'esprit
de la vème république puisque sur une
réforme constitutionnelle que j'ai fait
voter les textes de collectivités
territoriales viennent d'abord au sénat
donc la première expression politique de
l'ump
serein le groupe ump du sénat et nous
fixerons notre ligne mais notre ligne
elle est très majoritaire quasiment
unanime à l'intérieur du groupe
le maintien du département et pour
éviter les doublons toutes les régions
qui sont trop petit et qui ont tendance
à contenir is et leurs actions à se
comporter comme des départements à ce
moment là il faut les agrandir parce qu
on garde tous les échelons ne gardez pas
là tous les échelons parce que non non
vous ne gardez pas quand cordes quand
vous supprimez par deux le nombre de
régions déjà vous êtes vous avez une
division permis à tout le reste
non papa vous pouvez très bien supprimée
dans certains cas par exemple
départements en milieu urbain nous
parlons là notamment d'améliorer les
rejets la position du gouvernement sur
ce sujet la tension ce qui s'est passé
qui c'est mon héros célèbres esor ce qui
s'est passé à lyon et quelque chose
d'acceptable puisque ça a été voté par
un certain d'entre nous donc on peut
discuter de cela mais donc ce que nous
disons c'est que nous avons besoin d'un
espace de proximité la république c'est
de la proximité c'est pas une question
de niveau de collectivités territoriales
c'est une question républicaine où le
citoyen se re perdu quand le citoyen ne
comprend pas la démocratie est malade
alors justement ce que l'on doit
s'exprimer pour un peu plus de clarté
sur ce dossier ce que vous attendez de
lui une parole claire
bien sûr on en attend du président de la
république sur ce sujet une vision est
bon ce que nous voulons c'est qu'une
vraie vision stratégique parce que si je
prends les interventions depuis le mois
de janvier
c'est une politique en zigzag des allers
et retours département région va pouvoir
faire l'impasse d'une révision
constitutionnelle selon vous je ne le
crois pas où cette réforme est
ambitieuse il faut changer la
constitution
ou alors c'est de la cosmétique et là ce
sera très grave parce que les français
ont compris que ce big bang à ce
moment-là deviendrait une réforme
diversion pour occuper les territoires
pour occuper le débat politique parce
que naturellement tout le monde parle du
découpage de sa région etc mais ne
traite pas le vrai problème qu'est le
problème de l'emploi des pme des
artisans de l'agriculture de la vie
économique du pays
attention à ce que cette réforme ne soit
pas une réforme de diversion sur le
regroupement des régions qu'avez vous
pensé des propositions de ségolène royal
qui veut fusionner les pays de la loire
avec votre région du poitou charentes
je trouve que depuis qu'elle est
ministre elle a beaucoup de bonnes idées
et donc la soutenir cette idée je pense
que
vont écouter les habitants je pense que
il faut pas se comporter en fait au dos
et donc de dire tiens je vais discuter
avec les pays de la loire et puis moi je
fais une alliance poitou charentes
wah faut regarder les stratégies
faut regarder l'économie la vie des gens
et notamment les bassins de vie moi ce
que je peux vous dire par exemple pour
une région comme poitou-charentes sait
que traditionnellement notre histoire
c'est d'être le nord du sud donc plutôt
appartenir au sud mais dans est le nord
il se trouve qu'en aquitaine la capitale
bordeaux est au nord de l'aquitaine donc
la capitale bordeaux est un peu à mi
chemin d'un axe qui pourrait être le
nord de poitiers et la bonne ville de
pau est donc là on a en aquitaine une
cuve d'une capitale régionale qui sera à
peu près centrale donc ça nous paraît
être un projet avec le limousin mais ça
me gêne fixe rien c'est à la population
de d'apprécier de discuter et je ne veux
pas me comporter en grand féodal depuis
dimanche soir pour répondre à la colère
des électeurs vous proposer un big bang
institutionnels alors moderniser le
parlement rénover le sénat attention
vous allez faire peur aux sénateurs je
pense que les sénateurs ont peur car si
vous mettez en cause deux départements
vous mettez en cause de ces d'un grande
partie parce que le sénat à sept bases
républicaines que celle du département
je pense qu'on a besoin d'un ces deux-là
fort on a besoin d'un sénat qui a la foi
propose mais aussi qui sait résister qui
est capable d'éviter des bêtises j'ai vu
dans le passé récent des bêtises qu'ils
sont croyez vous qu aujourd'hui le sénat
de deux doigts de laquelle doit être
aujourd'hui nous ne connaissons pas les
dates des prochaines élections nous
connaissant pas non plus le temps ça a
été fixé aujourd'hui du sénat
mais je parle des comptonales des
régionales quelle date quel mode de
scrutin
quel territoire vous rendez compte cette
démocratie des territoires dont le sénat
est l'incarnation
nous n'avons aucune vision d'avenir on
peut pas dire aujourd'hui un maire les
régionales les copains les régions je
peux pas vous dire quand auront lieu les
élections et je ne peux pas vous dire
sur quelles bases elles auront lieu le
céreq souffre
je pense que le sénat
je pense je pense que le sénat doit
occuper sa place
il doit être plus rapide plus véloce il
doit être plus imaginatifs les doigts
est aussi politiquement résister dans la
république devrait avoir face à lui un
président du sénat qui aujourd'hui lui
dise ce dont nous avons besoin sur les
territoires et puis aussi sur la
démocratie transparence est ce qu'elle
est trop lente quand vous serez
président du sénat c'est ce que je dis à
françois on a chaque fois que je peux le
rencontrer et là effectivement c'est le
discours d'un candidat que vous tenez
pour la présidence du cncc le discours
d'un sénateur qui tient sa dignité qui
n'aiment pas apparaître dans la vie
politique comme un subalterne
ça fait longtemps qu'on voit les
pouvoirs et les responsabilités du sénat
progressivement décliné la république a
besoin du sénat elle a besoin de gens
modérés
elle a besoin de gens qui connaissent le
terrain de gens elle a besoin de ces
mêmes ne voulait pas dévoiler un peu vos
ambitions pour le sénat prévu d'avancer
masqué alors qu'on vous voit quand même
un peu en campagne je sais je n'avance
pas masqué si vous me demandez si je
suis candidat je vous répondrais
probablement mais il est clair que là
parce que vous êtes très attentif à tous
les maux mais il est clair que je suis
quelqu'un qui a une vision est dit
probable
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous découragez
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous empêcher
d'être candidat à la présidence du sénat
et bien que par exemple ce qui serait
très dommageable pour nous que la droite
et le centre n'est même pas la majorité
donc moi je veux tout faire pour qu'il y
ait une majorité au sénat donc je ne
veux pas faire de cette alternance je ne
sais pas je ne pense pas mais je ne sais
pas je suis vigilant mais pour moi la
candidature qui s'affiche dans une
ambition personnelle à un moment où ce
qui compte c'est l'alternance au sénat
ce qui compte c'est une vision pour le
sénat une pensée pour le sénat et le
retour à la dignité des sénateurs est
donc cette dignité des sénateurs il faut
la défendre
donc ça c'est mon projet je veux le
faire partager
mais je prendrai les décisions
définitives en tenant compte de la
situation car nous verrons nouvelle mort
d'enfants tenant compte de la situation
politique parce que nous sommes dans
une majorité qui est extrêmement serré
et je suis contre les divisions très
bien je peux le dire d'une future
majorité qui serait sans doute très
serré moi je suis content les divisions
je le montre à l'ump aujourd'hui c'est
moi qui avait rapproché copé et fillon
pour éviter un certain nombre de
difficultés à un moment c'est moi qui
parle avec les uns avec les autres
je suis quelqu'un qui rassemble je suis
pour que l'ailier dans ce projet
sénatorial un collectif et qu'une
candidature exprime seul existe si on a
compris qu'on serait quand même compris
des excellents je vous le disais
rapidement si j'ai le temps pour finir
jean pierre raffarin avant sur le budget
des armées parce que là encore c'est un
peu flou et françois hollande laisse
traîner la commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat demande aujourd'hui
à l'unanimité le respect de la loi de
programmation militaire vous soutenez
cette déclaration absolument absolument
autour du président carrère nous sommes
tout à fait convaincu que le travail des
effets présents socialiste mais qui sait
travailler avec les uns avec les autres
et nous avons beaucoup négocié sur cette
loi par la somme était à certains
d'entre nous l'ont voté pas tous mais il
ya eu un travail collectif qui a été
menée ce vote là doit être respectée et
nous souhaitons que le gouvernement
respecte le loi votée par le sénat est
ce que vous avez été surpris par le ton
de la lettre adressée par le ministre de
la défense jean yves le drian à françois
hollande justement pour lui demander de
défendre le budget des armées ssa un ton
très dur ça s'apparente mm un
réquisitoire
c'est un peu dur quand on pense que le
chef de l'état le chef des armées c'est
à dire qu'il est en première ligne sur
ce sujet donc il y avait un ton qui
étaient un ton un peu culpabilisant
c'est seulement en effet surpris de la
part de monsieur le drian qui est un
personnage tout à fait respectable et en
général autant modéré mais ça veut dire
vraiment que la menace était forte et
donc il faut pas faire de reproche à
monsieur le drian mais s'inquiétait de
la manoeuvre qui était en cours de
préparation
il avait raison sur le fond on a senti
il a entièrement raison sur le fond je
pense que le président de la république
a dû faire très vite les arbitrages
nécessaires
j'imagine j'imagine qu'ils alors en est
on
terne au gouvernement j'imagine qu'avec
le président de la république après ça
respect il est le chef des armées c'est
lui qui engage nos forces sur des
théâtres d'opérations qui sont très
risquées
donc c'est lui qui est le premier à être
attentif à l'aspect sauvage et rien au
hasard mais à raison et vous même de
reconnaître
effectivement il y avait ce ton
extrêmement dur et du ministre de la
défense on a senti qu'il mettait sa
démission dans la balance
ça n'est pas habituel d'une façon
générale ce genre de bras de fer à ce
point là entre un président de la
république un ministre c'est un c'est
assez rare même si j'ai vu dans le passé
des mauvaises humeurs de ministre des
finances qui par la suite est devenu
président de la république qui
n'appréciait pas les décisions de
l'ancien président la république sur la
loi de programmation militaire donc été
très grand loto un peu moins mais ils
avaient tous les deux du caractère la
peine de nous faire un dessin on a
compris
merci merci perrine merci monsieur
raffarin d'avoir est avec nous en ce
jour important nous l'avons dit pour
l'avenir de l'ump qui joue sa survie
vous l'avez dit tout à leur merci à très
vite